reflect the views and opinions of eight
news now or next our media group
i think there's been a big wake-up call
tonight on politics now from school
safety to teacher vacancies we talked to
the head of ccsd's teachers union about
getting ready to go back to class
there's just a lack of leadership and
involvement in day to day running in the
court system
the man who wants to take clark county
district attorney steve wolfson's job
will tell you what he says he can do
better
plus we'll tell you what happened in
nevada's governor's race this week while
republicans are asking one candidate to
step aside
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you very much for joining us here
on politics now i'm john langler so the
start of school is just a few weeks away
is clark county school district ready
well this week we spoke with the head of
the clark county education association
john bel ardita i asked the union leader
about the upcoming school year
let's just talk about what the
expectations are from your end for the
beginning of another school year
well we are working with the district to
make sure that we fill these positions
that need to be filled so that
classrooms have licensed professionals
and where they don't they have at least
a competent professional substitute in
place so that we start the school year
as best as possible
we're looking to make sure these schools
are safe given a lot of issues that have
emerged just this past year around the
safety issue
the co-vet precautions that the district
had in place in the past they've been
modified somewhat going into this school
year but they're still there what is the
vacancy rate right now how short
is ccsd well i think they went into
this school year
with
a little over 1400 vacancies okay
and i think the district is probably
close to 91 92
filling those vacancy numbers as of this
moment that we're talking for example
today they have a new higher orientation
with educators
they will continue to hire as the school
year goes on but i think they're
proceeding to fill those vacancies will
they fill all of them when the school
year opens no that's why we'll have a
need for a substitute are you concerned
or should parents be concerned with the
amount of vacancies within the district
i think every parent should be concerned
about what their classroom
is going to look like for their student
whether or not they have a licensed
professional or substitute i can tell
you we've just adjusted the starting
salary
uh for teachers it's over 50 000 it's
made a big difference in the district's
effort to recruit so we've seen a spike
in hiring so my message to parents is
that you know i think we're trying to
work through the
uh challenge just this week the school
district announced the addition of
cameras on buses as a way to sort of
help with school safety issues um is it
enough what else should the district be
doing well if anything ever happens
you'll find somebody will say it's not
enough right i think there's been a big
wake-up call that we have to make sure
that these campuses these buses these
classrooms have secure environments that
are safe for both educators and students
we've seen a rise of violent behavior in
this school district
and culminating in the heinous crime
that occurred at el dorado i think the
measures that the district is taking
right now are the right ones and it's in
the right direction i think it's not a
light switch solution though i think we
were talking 370 schools 300 000 kids uh
i think the district is on the path
addressing the high need areas first and
foremost we're comfortable with that is
it is it enough yet no
legislative sessions on the horizon uh
what are some of the priorities for ccea
funding
and we we
well it's more than as usual the last
legislative session passed a new funding
formula
and it's based on student needs and
equity and it needs to be funded on an
annual basis of 200 million dollars more
and so that's going to be a challenge in
the legislative session if if there's
not resources we can't talk about things
like improving safety things like having
the appropriate staff in these schools
you know we got a big bump with federal
dollars that's what's been paying for
some of this stuff we need ongoing uh
revenue and most of that comes from the
state so that's a priority for us end of
the last school year there's i think
there was a perception in the community
about uh acrimony at ccsd on the board
uh with administration with teachers
um and that hasn't really gone away it's
been quiet for the last couple of months
it's been summer obviously
how would you describe
just the lay of the land from your point
of view at ccsd right now your ability
to work with dr jarrah and his team to
work with the school board members and
what you're hearing from teachers
heading into this new school year so i
would describe our relationship with
administration as issue based it's very
frank and honest and transparent in
other words we don't try to get into the
politics that might be seen on the
school board
with the administration it's about hey
we have vacancies how do we resolve it
we have safety issues how do we resolve
it how do we try to retrieve lost
education as a result of the covet
experience for all these kids as well as
dealing with the challenges our
educators have whether they're
overworked and don't have the
appropriate resources or they themselves
have had some you know mental health
issues because of the stress of covet we
have an honest and i think transparent
issue based relationship with
administration
with the school board trustees i think
that's a work in progress i mean i we've
been advocates since the last
legislative session to look for a fix
where we can have a much more efficient
and competent and student focused
governing body here we're going to
pursue that
you can also hear mr valadin's response
to the ongoing idea of breaking up clark
county school district the full
interview is available at
eightnewsnow.com
a rent control initiative up in north
las vegas may not make the ballot after
all although city council members could
take up the issue again next week this
is a measure supported by the culinary
union it says it did turn in enough
signatures to qualify based on the 2019
general election voter numbers
north las vegas city clerk used the
number of voters from this year's
primary just uh back in june and on that
basis the city says the union did not
turn in enough signatures at the heart
of this disagreement an interpretation
of the nevada constitution the culinary
union's attorney has asked the city
council to take up this issue on
wednesday
now to the governor's race former
senator and former gubernatorial
candidate dean heller on the gop side he
is backing sheriff joe lombardo he's
also asking joey gilbert to drop his
lawsuit gilbert claims that some type of
irregular formula was used for the
election but he hasn't provided any
proof gilbert lost to lombardo by 26 000
votes in the june primary heller wants
gilbert to drop the lawsuit and he says
quit damaging the reputation of the
republican party
heller says the gop now needs unity to
defeat governor sisilak
speaking of governor sysolak this week
he touted the record number of jobs in
nevada right now he held an event this
week at the one stop career center and
highlighted the state's job retraining
programs one area though where jobs have
not fully fully returned is hospitality
the governor says returning conventions
though will help with that
clark county district attorney steve
wolfson will have to win a general
election this time around to keep his
seat republican timothy trevenger is
challenging the incumbent democrat i
spoke this week with trevenger about his
plans for the office
i jump into the race well part of it's i
believe in balance and i believe in
equality on both sides and the da's race
historically at least for the past
couple of cycles have just been a
democratic primary and when i saw that
no one was going to jump in on the
conservative side i felt was important
to have those voices recognized and
that's why i'm in this race what is it
about
mr wolfson's performance as uh as
prosecutor in clark county that concerns
you that you think you would do
differently if you were elected into
office sure i think mainly it comes down
to a matter of leadership i mean he is
not going into court and prosecuting
cases he has taken a very administrative
role i think because of that disconnect
between him and his deputies not all of
his policies are being enforced they're
not being done consistently
there's a lot of great attorneys in that
office there's just a lack of leadership
and involvement in day-to-day running in
the court system another issue you
brought up is family court and
corruption in family court what are some
examples that you think are happening
here in clark county well we have a lot
of issues in family court there's a lot
of inconsistency there too depending on
what department you're walking into it's
unclear how the law is going to be
applied we have contempt charges coming
up where people are not afforded the
right to counsel and are thrown in jail
for a period of time there's a lot of
different things there that i think can
either be handled better and if there
are people playing favorites or doing
corrupt things in family court that
should be investigated and that should
be prosecuted part of your past is your
own experience with with criminal
prosecution you entered a plea deal on
heroin charges back in 2015. maybe
explain to the to the viewers what
happened back then and maybe how that
experience has
changed you and maybe changed your your
practice and what you how you perceive
the justice system sure when i came out
of law school i expected to be a
prosecutor my entire career so being on
the other side of that table was
certainly a surreal experience
i went through the diversion program an
ex of mine developed a drug issue i was
trying to get her clean unfortunately in
the midst of trying to get her clean she
was selling drugs out of the house while
i wasn't home
police come and raid the house i end up
in the system myself i did i did do a
plea agreement for a possession charge i
went through the diversion program which
i am a huge proponent of that gives
people second chances who have never
been in trouble before or first time
offenders
had my case dismissed but i think it
gives me an appreciation of both sides
of the table not only have i been a
prosecutor and a criminal defense
attorney i've been a defendant i
understand what that process is like i
understand the benefits of those
programs and giving people certain
people chances because probation in my
opinion isn't hard if you follow the
rules and i think everybody deserves a
second chance but you know if you can't
work within that system the prison is
always there for you so i am hard on
crime i just believe in diversion
programs you talked about the diversion
programs and so forth uh there's some
specialty courts in in clark county
we've got the drug courts veterans
courts for example should those continue
do you think those are successes yes
veterans court in particular i think is
incredibly important those people go
through things and experience trauma
that most of us everyday people have
never been in the military would never
understand i think that that court in
particular is very important drug court
is incredibly important drugs are
wreaking havoc on this county it's part
of the reason that our crime rate is so
high and trying to get people clean so
that they don't keep going back through
the system over and over again is an
incredibly important thing i think those
programs could be expanded without going
too much into taxpayer pockets and i
believe that everybody should have
access to those programs right now the
da's office is kind of gatekeeping
everyone should be able to apply it
shouldn't be which prosecutor you get
decides what program you can go into
you can watch more of our interview with
mr treffinger including what he thinks
about the death penalty at eight newsnow
dot com
are we in a recession or not next on
politics now steps the federal
government is taking to slow down
inflation and the debate over what
actually counts as a recession plus
holding rental companies accountable
congress calls out one of nevada's
biggest for its treatment of tenants
politics now
toyota let's go places
welcome back to politics now
nevada democrats are still waiting to
see if the silver state gets to pick a
presidential candidate first in 2024 at
their last meeting the democratic
national committee floated the idea of
having nevada and new hampshire's
primary on the same day the
congressional hispanic caucus and the
latino victory fund have both endorsed
nevada going first in the primary
schedule a first vote a vote rather a
first vote on who would go first that is
scheduled to take place the first week
of august which is next week a final
decision is expected in the next month
or so
all right congress is considering a bill
which allows medicare to set drug prices
nevada senator catherine cortez masto
says ads being run against the
legislation and against her are
misleading this ad
incorrectly claims that i support a bill
that would strip
300 billion dollars from medicare
this couldn't be further from the truth
what i do know is that
the ad is a deliberate lie
so this ad the senator is talking about
is from a dark money group called
american prosperity alliance
it refers to a portion of president joe
biden's buildback better plan which
deals with prescription drugs it would
let medicare directly negotiate
prescription prices with drug companies
the congressional budget office
estimates it would save 288 billion
dollars over 10 years senator cortez
masto's office says that money will be
used to cut out of pocket costs on
medicare part d and continue affordable
care act tax credits
this week the federal reserve announced
it will raise interest rates for the
fourth time this year
the move is designed to help curb
inflation and fight off a potential
recession washington d.c correspondent
rashad hudson reports
interest rates are headed up again for
the fourth time since march the federal
reserve is raising interest rates this
time by three quarters of a point these
rate hikes have been large and they've
come
they've come quickly and
it's likely that their full effect has
not been felt by the economy this will
impact people buying cars houses or
taking out a loan fed chair jerome
powell says the increase is necessary to
slow the economy and reduce the 9.1
percent inflation rate the highest in
nearly 40 years we didn't expect a good
reading but this one
this one was was even worse than
expected i would say powell aims for
inflation to be around two percent while
the white house argues that the u.s is
not headed for a recession senate
republican leader mitch mcconnell
doesn't believe it clearly something
isn't adding up house republicans like
louisiana congressman steve scalise say
president biden's policies are driving
up inflation joe biden won't look the
american people in the eye and admit
that his programs have failed chairman
powell says there will likely be another
rate hike in september how much depends
on what's up with inflation we need to
see inflation coming down
that was rashad hudson reporting it was
the second straight quarter of negative
gdp growth as well that has been a
marker of a recession in the past
a clark county lands bill introduced by
senator cortez masto is not moving
forward the bill designated federal land
for clark county to develop it was
adjusted to meet the requirements of
some activists and developers leaving
about 25 000 acres still a lot of land
clark county objected to the compromise
version though so senator cortez masto
pulled it from consideration
calling out siegel sweets next on
politics now the new congressional
report targeting a major nevada company
and its handling of evictions
plus why does wheda international
airport still say mccarran so much we'll
tell you what has the process on hold
next on politics now
monday live at 11 on 8 news now
you're watching politics now
a group of republicans say they are
backing democratic attorney general a
run ford's re-election campaign former
state gop chairwoman amy tarkanian
former congressman john porter lobbyist
mike hillerby and former state senate
majority leader michael roberson are all
involved in this
ford's republican opponent is attorney
seagal chatta she's best known for suing
the state over covett regulations this
group of republicans says ford has a
track record of delivering for nevada
tenants kicked out while a corporation
profits that's what federal lawmakers
are saying that happened right here in
southern nevada the 8 news now i-team's
vanessa murphy has more on a scathing
report about a major landlord in
southern nevada
familiar with them the siegel suites
they're all around town in southern
nevada and in several other states now
federal lawmakers say the owners used
abusive tactics to deceive tenants
putting them out on the street in the
middle of the pandemic while the company
collected covet 19 relief money those
are your tax dollars it was really
just a list of all of the really bad
things we've seen over the course of the
last two years during the pandemic jim
birchtold is the directing attorney for
the consumer rights project at legal aid
center of southern nevada which has
helped many former siegel suites tenants
is this still happening with the siegel
group here in southern nevada
i have nothing to indicate that it is no
longer happen
according to the congressional select
subcommittee's 39 page report the siegel
group harassed tenants and potentially
broke the law to evict them during the
cdc's eviction moratorium by tricking
the tenants into thinking the moratorium
wouldn't protect them in an email from a
property manager to a siegel vice
president i love getting to say that
this means eviction might happen sooner
than expected and seeing the look on
their faces smiley face the report
states a segal executive directed
managers to bluff people out the report
also includes an email with strategies
to get rid of a tenant if it looks like
there are too many occupants in the unit
and some are kids call child protective
services are we knocking on our door at
least twice a night or replace the
working ac with a non-working ac the
report points out siegel experienced
almost no revenue decline even during
the most disruptive time early on in the
pandemic and received a 2.32 million
dollars in paycheck protection program
loans in august of 2020 which the
company doesn't have to pay back it's
now been referred to the consumer
financial protection bureau for
investigation to the federal trade
commission for investigation we're
hoping that every entity
at the state level is taking a critical
look at this report to see if additional
action is warranted the report also
states the siegel group evicted at least
89 tenants who had pending rental
assistance applications
reporting in las vegas vanessa murphy
live local now
the siegel group did send eight news now
a statement it reads in part the siegel
group has at all times been committed to
abiding by the letter and the spirit of
the law applicable to our operations
unquote you can find a full statement
and the scathing report at
eightnewsnow.com
efforts to finish renaming reed
international airport are in a holding
pattern the process is supposed to be
paid for with donations but county
records show no money has been raised
this year
local democrats as you know led the
effort to make the swap in honor of late
former democratic senator harry reid
even after a big announcement back in
december many old signs for mccarran
airport remained there even today
initially more than 4 million dollars in
private donations was raised for the
project this week clark county
commissioner tick sega bloom
acknowledged they still need nearly 3
million dollars to finish
he said asking for donations in an
election year is a challenge but quote
it's going to happen
next on
politics now policing the police how you
can be on metro's citizens review board
coming up next
cash back chase make more of what's
yours
you're watching politics now
clark county is looking for people to be
on metro police's citizens review board
the group reviews complaints and
internal affairs investigations filed
against local officers the board has 25
members terms are three years they're
voluntary they're unpaid we have a link
to apply if you're interested though at
eightnewsnow.com
next week in what to watch more back to
school events clark county school
district is wrapping up summer classes
of course and teachers and support staff
will head back to their campuses to get
ready for the new school year and once
again class starts at ccsd august 8th
which is coming very quickly
that'll do it for us here on politics
now we thank you so much for watching
you can stay up to date online with all
the political news at eightnewsnow.com
have a good week we will see you back
here on saturday take care
[Music]
[Music]
you